yves smith called tylenol could be risky
for pregnant women a new review of 25
years of research finds acetaminophen
may contribute to adhd and other
developmental disorders in children
give me my screen back for just a second
zach so that i can pull up the
actual article which this person uh who
is one of the lead authors on the
article actually is referring to it is
ann bower who is the lead author on the
article it's confusing the way this is
written it's not eve smith
but it doesn't doesn't much matter oh
you're yeah this person is not in the uh
yeah you're right okay so here's the
article
in
boy what is it published in nature
reviews endocrinology
consensus statement paracetamol used
during pregnancy a call for
precautionary action
so we're just going to read one the
opening paragraph of the introduction
and then show the two figures before we
talk about this a little bit a growing
body of experimental and epidemiological
research suggests the prenatal exposure
to paracetamol that's an acetyl p
aminophenol apap otherwise known as
acetaminophen otherwise known as tylenol
might alter fetal development which
could in turn increase the risks of
certain neurodevelopmental reproductive
and urogenital disorders
okay and then they they do this review
and here are the two figures which are
um a good
view in here
figure one associations between prenatal
tylenol exposure reproductive and
neurobehavioral development suggest
suggested from observational human
studies so um it's not
uh ethical to do experiments on
humans it's generally understood with
something that is considered to be
potentially a risk so this is purely
observational studies
but thailand exposure in pregnancy
can lead to genital malformations in
boys
in neonates in childhood an increase in
adhd autism hyperactivity behavioral
difficulties and lower iq and language
capabilities in girls
and in adolescence and adulthood
can increase the rate of early puberty
onset in girls and then we have in
animal studies uh figure two just next
page
um
when exposed to
to tylenol
we have
lower rates of steroidogenesis
and of germ cells which is likely to
decrease fertility increase in dna
damage in juveniles lowered rates of
cognitive performance in boys of
locomotion and girls
or higher higher rates of locomotion in
girls that's interesting probably higher
activity lower motor skills lower
spatial learning and then in adulthood
we have
fertility problems increase in male
sexual behavior lowering lowering of
social behavior and learning in memory
and habituation so all sorts of known
effects
of early exposure to
tylenol
which the authors also say
is understood to be one of the
absolutely safest drugs on the market
and is widely um recommended to pregnant
women
because so many other things like nsaids
are understood to have risks
and one more thing before before you
start bread one of the things that that
they also point out is that tylenol
acetaminophen is a background drug in a
vast majority of other drugs so you know
most of many of i don't know most many
of the opiates that people would get
prescribed for pain
have acetaminophen in them as as one of
the ingredients and in fact
some amount of um
opiate poisoning is likely to be tylenol
poisoning
yes
because the opiates are addictive and
the tylenol is actually quite toxic
which is something you and i have talked
about on this program specifically with
regard to in concert with drinking
alcohol it's especially apparently
alcohol changes the pathway through
which tylenol is broken down in the
liver into a more one with a toxic
byproduct i believe is the analysis and
so absent alcohol it's less dangerous
but even absent alcohol it's extremely
toxic right so
uh eve smith who wrote the naked
capitalism article that calls attention
to the ann bower article that you were
just citing
says that effectively she says i must
confess that one reason i am running
this piece is that i have long and
loudly maintained that acetaminophen aka
tylenol is too dangerous to be sold over
the counter less than two times the
recommended dose level is considered
toxic
mind you its dangers have been known for
decades since she cites a 2004 article
that says acetaminophen overdose is a
leading cause for calls to poison
control centers over a hundred thousand
a year and accounts for more than fifty
six thousand emergency room visits 2600
hospitalizations and an estimated
458 deaths due to acute liver failure
each year
that's in the u.s
i believe that is in the u.s
now i looked into it a little bit so
really extraordinary numbers yes they
are really extraordinary numbers now i
was aware of the
toxicity of it and my thought and i
think what i've in fact said which i am
now revising
is that the thing about tylenol is it's
very toxic but at least we know what the
toxicity is it's liver toxicity which
you can afford yep right i think we both
said that right this doesn't suggest
that at all the liver toxicity thing is
very serious but what uh you were just
talking about all of these effects on
pregnant women and
fetuses and development of the children
that then result right
that's obviously a whole different level
of hazard now what's interesting is in
preparation for talking about this i
started i just really went after the
date of the invention of uh paracetamol
acetaminophen tylenol all the same thing
and i was shocked at how far back it
goes right first synthesized in 1877
really yes
1877 as a replacement for a
very dangerous drug but apparently it
has been beset by concerns over
safety for the entire period from 1877
i was amazed at that myself
from 1877
up through
1950
is where it is understood to be safe
enough to use but still major concerns
about safety
until in the 70s it overtakes aspirin
right and it starts to be understood to
be the safe alternative and recommended
very
casually to people for any sort of pain
they may have well i don't know i don't
know my history of drug development here
at all but i don't know or drug
development and understanding of toxic
effects but
ray's syndrome about which every modern
american at least parent is going to be
familiar with because you are told the
point that you're you're pregnant okay
you absolutely must not give children
under 18 i think it is aspirin because
rey's syndrome so i want you know i
wonder if that overtaking
um by tylenol of aspirin in terms of uh
its its prevalence in use as sort of a
over-the-counter pain relief might have
coincided with a recognition um that
aspirin actually had toxicity for young
children
um
yes i think this is strongly likely i
would point out that based on you know a
composite of what we that is to say you
and i now know about the various drugs
available
what are the safe alternatives for
children and pregnant women
well there probably aren't any
right this seems to suggest that tylenol
has significant hazards right
right significant hazards for
development
the
nsaids like ibuprofen carry risk to the
heart
aspirin carries the risk of rise
syndrome or raised syndrome however
however you pronounce it
you know ironically
if i had to guess based on what we
understand about these molecules i would
guess that the opiates are likely to be
the safest now they obviously have an
addictive danger right and an overdose
danger and all sorts of stuff like that
but but with
without all the fillers
taken in extreme moderation
um
in part because they are actually or are
closely mimicking
molecules that we are already producing
and therefore our bodies have an ability
to break them down safely exactly so is
that logic bomb proof no there's lots of
room you know you can add a hydrogen and
change a molecule from a benign one to a
toxin but
but the fact is the chances of it being
safer are pretty high right which
doesn't tell you what to do about the
addictive problem obviously that kills a
tremendous number of people especially
if you have uh drug companies uh
cryptically profiting from an epidemic
of addiction
but whatever i guess the point is look
if you really understood the story of
tylenol
it's a story of toxicity from the
beginning and it's a story of our
changing perceptions and changing
understanding and how that interfaces
with what's available to us over the
counter would it be
you know would a good system ever have
declared it safe enough
i don't know but you know i certainly
have always found it odd that it exists
in
nyquil
in combination with alcohol yeah right
like
if what we understand about alcohol
affecting the metabolism of tylenol is
true
that doesn't make any sense i mean
frankly the well you'll poison yourself
but at least you sleep well
right i guess
uh all right so anyway it's a very
interesting
uh puzzle we should put the links of
course to the naked capitalism article
and the article that it cites which
you've shown the figures from in the
description people can look into it
further
[Music]